hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm going to
explain an intriguing thriller and
horror fiction thailand series from girl
from nowhere season 2 called pregnant
because it is an anthology series each
episode will present a different story
and you will be able to understand the
storyline without having to watch the
previous episodes
this episode has an unpredictable plot
twist watch it till the end to find out
the movie starts with a backsound saying
that everyone in this world strives for
equality but many people do not take
equal responsibility for mistakes they
made together nanai is a popular guy at
school and is in line to become the next
school president he is also known as a
bad boy who has apparently knocked up
half of the girls in school most of whom
were forced to get abortions out of
shame
as usual nano is introduced at the
classroom as the new student
nanai who is in the same class with nano
has already put interest in her and is
ready to lure her one of her classmates
look me suggest nana to not fall for him
because she is going to be taken
advantage of despite warning from her
nano feels challenged and says that it
is okay as long as she does not get
pregnant
few moments later nanai and nano are
already getting closer as they are
having lunch together
because of that nanai's best friend
chang is forced to sit with other
students
lukmi states that their relationship
won't last long and nana will be dumped
as soon as he gets into her pants
motivated by what she just said they
decide to place bets on how long it
takes for nanai to get into her pants
chang spreads the betting idea and
starts to gather the money from other
students in the school
nanai and nano's relationship is getting
better and better exhibiting all signs
of a couple that is madly in love
as the bets begin nano meets patch a
pregnant girl who was the victim of
nanai pech tells nano that the entire
school students are taking bets on her
claiming that she does not want nano to
be the next victim
instead nano suggests pets not to think
of herself as a victim
long story short the couple starts
flirting with each other in the locker
room alone
nano challenges deny to describe the
exact time they have been together and
he manages to answer it with the right
answer it is three days three hours and
31 minutes
at first nano refuses to kiss an eye but
when he says that he will do anything
for her and love has no time limitations
nano starts a countdown from 10 and they
finally make out the next day nanai
shares his experience with nano to chang
claiming that it is his best record
which is 3 days 3 hours and 33 minutes
the bet is finally finished and it's
time to reveal the winner
it turns out that the most correct
duration is predicted by nano who
finally takes all the money
we discover that nano purposely did a
countdown when making out with nanai to
ensure that the duration is the same as
she placed on the bed as she leaves the
class she flashes the cash to an eye and
tells him that he just got played by her
meanwhile the knight starts to feel
under the weather
later on nano approaches him at the
toilet and they start to make out again
but this time he is unable to get the
desire he wants and leaves
in front of the other students nanai
states that he wants to break up with
her for looking at him like an object
and nano suddenly starts to laugh like
crazy saying that she doesn't see a
difference as nanai also sees girls as
an object
after that event nano sits with patch
and discovers that patch was trying to
do an abortion and failed
she also declares that it is the first
time she is glad to fail at something
a few moments later nana begins to hook
up with another girl but the girl
screams and runs away when she sees an
eyes bloated belly nanai starts vomiting
and having big mood swings
when he heads to the doctor it is
revealed that he is actually pregnant
the doctor states that the pregnancy has
reached 16 weeks and it's a baby girl
the next day the gossip of nanai's
bloated belly has spread it across the
school he is no longer the model student
he's portrayed to everyone
he then starts a fight with chang where
he unintentionally reveals to the entire
school that he is pregnant nano who is
recording the entire fight shares the
video to all students in the school
nanai finally gets a taste of his own
medicine and starts regretting
everything he had done
nanai has lost all his social standing
and future opportunities he is no longer
the model student he's portrayed to
everyone
knowing the truth his father pressures
him to get an abortion and he is
expelled from his own house until the
problem is resolved
he now has to live in a small dirty
apartment popping pills he does his best
to swallow the abortion pill but he
eventually finds himself vomiting that
vomit soon turns into blood as he cries
in the bathroom wincing in pain
nanai grabs a knife and is ready to stab
himself in the belly
thankfully a knock at the door stops him
a mysterious girl dropped a note and
after reading that he realizes that nano
is the one who got him pregnant
the next day he confronts nano at school
with his new look to find out what nano
had done to him
nano ignored him telling him it was just
a bit of fun
desperated nanai approaches patch and
apologizes for what happened between
them in the past she forgives him and
tells him it is okay because she has
made peace with her decision
as they hug each other pitch wishes him
good luck and walks away
fast forward nanai finally gives birth
to his daughter he actually paid the
doctor to get rid of the baby but
instead the doctor says that he has to
do it himself nanai then becomes a
single father at first he attempts to
harm the baby but with the baby cooing
and wrapped in the blanket he finally
accepts the baby and starts
breastfeeding her nano visits nanai and
he apologizes to her begging her to come
back but refused by nano she brings him
a gift and immediately shuts the door in
his face then walks away
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching